hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast the genetics of aquaculture
genotyping with GBS and arrays for
species identification and trade
improvement I'm Robert castellanos of
lab roads and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab lives and sponsored by
thermo Fisher Thermo Fisher Scientific
Inc is a world leader in serving science
with revenues of 17 billion and
approximately 50,000 employees in 50
country our mission is to enable our
customers to make the world healthier
cleaner and safer they have a few
important announcements before we begin
this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window
have any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window and submit
your problems to bring join a botany I'd
like to introduce today's speakers dr.
Beecham and dr. balton today's first
speaker is dr. Beecham dr. Beecham has
been a research scientist in fisheries
in oceans canada for the past 37 years
largely at the Pacific Biological
Station in Nanaimo British Columbia he
is the head of stock identification
research within the molecular genetic
laboratory and has to examine genetic
variations to evaluate population
structure and associated stock
identification applications across the
range of Pacific salmon species as
employed almonds many satellites
microsatellites and single nucleotide
polymorphisms
snips and salman stock identification
applications this current focus is to
evaluate and apply parentage based
tagging and genetic stock identification
techniques for chinook and coho salmon
and British Columbia particularly for
hatchery populations this work is
conducted by developing panels for
primers that amplifies specific
fragments of DNA amplicons and single
PCR reactions and then direct DNA
sequencing of the amplicon is employed
in order to genotype individuals at
selected snips in the amplicon I'll now
turn it over to the doctor for his
presentation oh well today I'm going to
talk about the parentage based tagging
and genetic identification for chinook
and coho salmon it's some work that
we've been doing here in British
Columbia for the past few years now the
main focus of after they stock is
parentage based tagging so that the
underlying the principle of parent is
based a gain is that if you sample and
genotype the brood stock at a hatchery
then this will provide genetic tags for
the offspring of the of the parents and
we can recover these tags through
statistical parentage and analysis now
since this tagging process really only
requires genotyping the parents and
these parents can produce thousands of
offspring that are released from from
the hatchery that parent is based Diegan
is very highly efficient at marking now
when the juveniles are released from a
hatchery they can be adipose fin clipped
for chinook salmon if they have a coat
of our tag and for for coho in southern
British Columbia all the hatchery
production is adipose fin clipped so if
you sampled the
clipped fish upon when they returned to
to their spawning locations if you
sample the clip fish that you should
then be able to use their parentage
based tagging to identify these
individuals back to their parents so
that should provide the hatchery and a
year of release so this is the same
information that we get from our current
color tag program so so basically what
we're doing is we're genotyping the
parents and a hatchery the offspring are
released then they rear in the ocean for
a number of years if they're coho they
can rear in the ocean for one or two
years chinook may be up to five or six
years when when they come back as mature
adults then if we sample the clip fish
in fisheries we could then use
statistical parentage analysis to
identify the individuals back to their
parents and thus to the hatchery and and
their year of release so you know we
have this coat of our tag program where
physical tags are inserted into the
nasal cartilage of individuals when it
released from I hatchery under
subsequently sampled when when they
would return so what we're looking at is
can we use genetics based system to
provide similar kinds of information
where we have fish that or our sampled
and highly mixed up ocean fisheries and
can we use the genetic information to
identify individual fish to specific
hatcheries and year of release when it
can be a very large number of
geographically diverse populations
contributing to a mixed dock sample from
a fishery
now we were doing this through a process
called amplicon sequencing and that is
where primers are applied in a panel and
are used to target and amplify specific
fragments of DNA known to contain snips
or soon will nucleotide polymorphisms
and what amplicons sequencing does it
provides us with a cost-effective way to
screen for hundreds of snips now our
current panel for coho we currently have
of 304 amplicons that are produced in
our panel in a single pcr and we're
tracking 357 snips in those 304
amplicons for chinook salmon our current
panel produces 319 amplicons and we're
currently tracking 419 snips and we do
all of our sequencing on an iron torn
proton okay so the objective of our work
and the focus of my talk today is was to
evaluate if the effectiveness of their
direct amplicon sequencing for stock
identification of chinook and coho
salmon now when we have your sample at
our hatchery we can get the samples of
fin clips that there are put on blotter
paper they then come into our lab we can
extract DNA from from those fish either
using robotics or violent we've also
been recently using a cadet space
extraction method and once the DNA is
extracted we normalize it using our tika
and robotics to a concentration of 40
nanograms per
milliliter ok so once we have our
extracted DNA and we have it normalized
we then use our primer pools we have
separate ones for both chinook and for
for coho and this is where we do our
amplification pcr where for for coho
once we use our panel we then expecting
to get up to 300 for amplicons for each
individual so after the amplicons have
been present we we then take our we then
go into the second stage our second pcr
where we digest the ends of the
amplicons and the reason and again we do
that using robotics and the reason we do
that is so that we can legate our bar
codes or to the amplicons now these
barcodes identify the individual fish
we're currently using 384 barcodes we
expect to go to 768 quite soon we will
probably be obtaining the additional 384
barcodes on a on a trial basis sometimes
this year
okay so then once we have our our
amplicons that have been with the
individual barcodes ligated to them we
then clean up the reaction again and we
then combine our individual libraries
currently 384 we're going to 768 in the
near future we would then put them on
the Iron Chef we and chef would then
load the the chips that we were then put
into our on toward proton for actually
sequencing ok so for stock
identification there's there's two main
methods that we can use and the first
method is parents is based tagging where
the individuals are to be identified or
genotyped and then if possible we match
them to their prospective parents
through statistical parentage analysis
the software that we actually use is
called snippet so we don't need any
genetic differentiation among individual
populations contributing to a fishery
when we use this analysis all we need is
some differences among parents now the
second method that we use is genetic
stock identification where the genetic
profiles of whole populations that are
potentially contributing to a mixed
example we use those to estimate the
stuff composition of the sample and in
some instances we estimate the origins
of the individual fish in those mixtures
so far our basic data for coho salmon
where we're looking at a hundred and
seventeen populations to date we've
surveyed over 20,000 individuals across
those 117 populations are mean no call
rate over the 302 snips that we use for
population structure stock ID work is
2.7% with a with a range from 1.4 to 14
I should point out that we have 300 for
amplicons so one of them we use to
identify the sex of the individual and
the second one we use is to identify the
species chinook and coho would be the
most likely to be misidentified so we
have a species ID snip on the panel so
we we don't use those two snips when we
do our parentage analysis or our stock
ID work so for the 302 snips that we use
we have mean coverage rate of two
hundred and sixty three times and so
we're we have lots of room on our chip
to add additional individuals to a chip
and to have additional primers in our
pool and that would still allow us to
have a reasonable coverage rate of about
30 times now for our our coho panel we
have a coho origin primers that we
originally that were originally I
identified in ink level you have 250 of
those we have their the rest a little
over 50 from chinook origin primers now
some of our amplicons have more than one
snip / amplicon that we track a so we're
tracking 304 amplicons and in those
amplicons we're
we're tracking 376 nips for parentage
analysis we only use one snip or
amplicon and but for genetic stock
identification it is possible to use
haplotype frequencies so the additional
snips that we are tracking will see
application in our appetite frequency
work now we have surveyed 117
populations there from a range of
locations here so we we have some here
in South insultas of Alaska we we have a
number of populations in queen charlotte
islands or Haida Gwaii we also have them
in northern British Columbia where the
NASA and skena rivers are in the Central
Coast on the east and west coast of
Vancouver Island and then we have them
in the lower Fraser River and here in
the Thompson River which is a tributary
of the Fraser then we have them down
here in Puget Sound in Washington now
it's important when we do in genetic
stock identification that there be a
regional population structure and that's
precisely what we have as an example
here this is a dendrogram that's based
on that the
as the frequencies the allele
frequencies at that 302 snips that we
have and can see here we have a Thompson
River component that's quite that's
quite distinct and here we have a lower
Fraser River component we have a nut
number of populations in that group
here's all of our our Puget Sound
populations that we've looked at and
here we have our east coast of Vancouver
Island and over here we have our what we
call the Georgia Strait mainland these
are our populations on mainland bc that
or north of vancouver and then here we
have some populations from the west
coast of Vancouver Island so can
continuing on yeah these are our
populations from the Queen Charlotte
Islands or what's what's now known as
Haida Gwaii all through here and you can
see that we have a number of populations
on the central coast of British Columbia
so that the take home message here here
is that there's a strong regional
population structure in coho so how does
that relate to stew stock ID well what
we we wanted to test the accuracy of
hours of our about when we determine the
the origins of fish so in in this year
we when the juveniles were fin clipped
from various hatcheries we asked that
some that the Frenchman clips be saved
we we had hoped to get a
a hundred per hatchery so Vic because we
knew what hatchery they came from and
when they were clipped these were our
nolan origin samples and that's what we
have here all of our juveniles so we
were able to then because we had already
genotype the brood stock we would then
be able to use our parentage analysis to
identify them back to their parents and
here we had a sample of coated wire
tagged individuals so we knew because
they work or are tagged what hatchery
they came from so when we made the
assignments via snippet five parentage
analysis we were able to assign 926 of
those individuals and we assign them
with 100% accuracy both respect to
population and age when we had a
potential donor populations of 117
populations over multiple brood years
when we couldn't make the assignment by
a snippet we then pass those individuals
to be assigned by a GSI and you can see
that we did a pretty good job of
assigning those individuals to their
respective populations overall we had 99
right here that we assigned by a GSI and
our overall Simon accuracy was about
eighty four percent so we have a one
hatchery inch Creek in the lower part of
the Fraser where we have sampled brood
stock in two thousand six nine 12 14 and
15 so that allowed us to do some
assignments of individuals in the brood
stock and you can see that in our first
year of
the assignments that was the 2009 boost
up we assigned a hundred and fifty four
of those individuals to the correct
population being inch Creek and to the
correct Brewed year which was 2006 coho
salmon typically have a three year life
cycle in British Columbia most of the
individual mature at age three although
there are apportion males that mature at
age two and these are known as jacks and
you can see that overall ok I should
point out in 2014 we only I could
identify seven individuals in the brood
stock by parentage analysis this was
because we didn't have samples from the
2011 boots out which would have been the
the parents although we did identify we
did assign seven individuals to the 2012
brood stock and these were the jacks
that were incorporated into the 2014
brood stock but overall any assignments
that we made via snippet were correct to
both population and to the age of the
individual there were some assignments
by a GSI to some populations in the
lower part of the Fraser we're not sure
if these were assignment errors or
actual strays they could be actual
strays as origin fish of state river
origin are also transported to rearing
at the inch Creek hatchery and then
there they're taken back to inch just a
river for release so it is possible
we've had some strays coming into the
integrated stock
so it is possible to use genetic stock
identification to assign individuals to
specific regions we have our co2 are
tagged program that had 23 predefined
regions where individuals can be
assigned to so we had to probability
levels in terms of checking the accuracy
of our assignments of individual fish to
these regions the first probability
level was at the fifty percent level so
if we if our assignment probability was
less than fifty percent we discarded
these fish from the analysis you can see
that of the of the approximately
nineteen thousand fish that we assigned
we are overall assignment accuracy to
one of these twenty three regions was
about ninety six percent when we went to
a higher level of confidence at the we
had to have assignment at eighty-five
percent level we had an overall accuracy
of 98.4 percent as assignment to region
so our next steps well we're going to be
sampling jacks that are returning in
2016 and to the Canadian hatcheries
we're going to be analyzing that the
boot stock from from those hatcheries
we're going to be adding additional
populations from from the Thompson goes
to Washington and Columbia and Oregon
for our gsi side of our application and
we're also increasing the number of
amplicons that were going to be driving
from the panel from 304 we are just
having the panel redesigned we're adding
another 260 primer pairs to the pool so
we hope to have approximately between
five and six hundred
amplicons that would be derived from
single pc are switching briefly to
chinook we have this same type of result
in chinook salmon we have a regional
population structure which is again what
you want to see when you come in to do
genetic stock identification Oh as an
example here we have all of our here we
have all of our populations that we've
sampled on the west coast of Vancouver
Island okay so we we've done the same
type of analysis for Chinook as we as I
previously outlined for coho we had fin
clips sampled from juveniles for that
for 2016 so these would have been
parents from these would've been
offspring from the 2015 parents we've
analyzed them in our lab where we're
still in the process we haven't quite
finished all the of the boots up and
analysis of all of the 2015 brood stock
and and and that's that's the reason why
we were only eight to identify only five
individuals to parent said at the quincy
battery on east coast of Vancouver
Island we still haven't analyzed all of
the brood stock for that they could
hatchery but for for the others when
we've made the assignments we again with
respected just like chinook and coho
when you made the assignments we they
were signed with a hundred percent
accuracy to population and age you can
see down here at the at the chehalis
hatchery and southern bc we had two
stocks
released from that hatchery we
identified them accurately and we were
quite pleased to see those results so
again this comes to the genetic stock
identification component of the
application where we have hatcheries
where color tags are applied these fish
are adipose fin clipped upon release and
if we look at how well we can identify
these fish to specific hatcheries so
that this is looking at our brood stock
you can see here that by and large we
can do a pretty good job these are some
hatcheries here on the mainland of
british columbia chilliwack is in the
lower fraser chehalis is in the lower
fraser Nicola is in the thompson river
drainage and you can see down here we
have these are populations on east coast
of Vancouver Island and then Robertson
here is on the west coast of Vancouver
Island so overall we can do a quite a
good job of identifying individual fish
through specific hatcheries so the the
overall question does PBT actually work
if there are lots of population shift
choices you know there are some skeptics
esta or critics that a genetic method
could work and in terms of identifying
fish to individual populations when you
had a large
number of populations that work there
could be a potentially assigned to so
the answer seems to be yes that assign
just made my snippet appear to be
accurate and also that accurate
assignment indicates the hatchery
release and year release so it gives you
the age of the individual and so that
parentage based tagging can provide the
equivalent information to that from core
wire tags so we get the individuals plus
the identification to families so
basically we think that we can have a
genetic method of stock identification
this particular parentage based tagging
as a possible assessment tool and
because the results for the assignment
of no larger samples and worked out well
we're planning a large-scale trial to
southern British Columbia coho salmon in
in 2017 and 2018 and then you know if we
can apply it successfully we're
providing an option between a cohort AG
program and a parent is based tagging
program for manners and Fisheries and
Oceans well the bottom line is will
apparently space tagging be applied in
Canadian hatcheries we're not sure we
would we'll provide our managers and
staff with the option to choose and i'll
wrap it up there with some
acknowledgement of our funding agencies
our cocoa work is funded through a
genome Canada project that were involved
in with a number of Canadian
universities and I think I'll leave it
at that and I'm happy to answer any
questions
okay well thank you so very much doctor
for your amazing presentation we do have
some questions and we do have some time
to allow to answer those the first
question today is for you doctor is what
is the time taken to analyze a group of
384 samples in the lab well in our lab
and we have one person who does the
extractions so I'm thinking of what we
can do in a week we have one person who
would who works for three days who would
extract 16 plates of 96 fish so that
would be fifteen hundred and thirty six
fish per per week we have one person who
works Shh five days five short days and
she runs all of the plates through a
through the Iron Chef she was she she
she does the library build she runs the
place through the Iron Chef and the Ion
Torrent so she run so so we do to chef
runs per week and each chef ron has two
chips each chip as 384 fish so we have
essentially four days for seven half
hour working days for that person and we
have one person who does the essentially
the bioinformatics for that run so
basically then then that would be one
day so we have eight working days to run
approximately fifteen hundred and
thirty-six fish so I guess the
long-winded answer is would take us
about two
we'll work in two person working days to
analyze 384 fish but it would be done
over a period of three days thank you
and so our next question is going to be
what is the genome coverage of the snip
markers were they pretty selected based
on suspected or known importance in the
adaption of summons well the genome
coverage of our markers we've looked at
that through our genome Canada project
dr. Ben Cooper University of Victoria is
sequencing the coho salmon genome and
we've taken advantage of that by
providing our our amplicon sequence
information to 2dr coupe and he has
mapped them to the coho genome and we
have found that the amplicons are well
distributed over all 30 chromosomes that
are present in the indica whole genome
we've also done that for chinook salmon
and again we have found that those snips
those amplicons are well distributed
across the genome coming back did we
select them know when we put our panels
together I simply tried to use all of
the known snips for both species that
that were available and provided the
sequence information to thermo fisher
and and they designed the the
primers for us and we've just to use
them as best we could now not all the
snips were what was it possible to
obtain primers for and there are some
snips that we've attained primers for
that we've subsequently discarded
because of heterozygosity or high
weinberg issues and so what what we've
left with or now are ones that are
heterozygosity is less than fifty
percent and the tend to be in
hardy-weinberg I thank you very much and
what is the repeatability of the
genotype scores and this will be our
last question for today recently and we
found that when we ran about I think was
around a hundred and twenty thousand
genotypes we compared gene types for all
other 302 snips we had a about a hundred
and twenty thousand genotypes are
genotyping error rate was I think one
point zero seven percent across across
those so it's about what one would
expect using this de stipe of platform
for genotyping alright thank you and
doctor gave any final comments before we
let you go
one happy to have the opportunity to
provide some update on Howard we're
doing in our lab on our chicken coop
applications and if there are any
additional questions I'll be pleased to
answer them
I would like to introduce dr. Paulson al
dr. Paul piece has been with the USDA
Agricultural Research Service since 2001
he currently holds the position of a
research to nemesis and lead scientist
of the genetics physiology and genomics
unit at the National Center for cool &
Co water aquaculture where he leads
efforts to develop tools and resources
for genomic research in rainbow trout
and other salads the major genomic tools
and resources that were developed for
rainbow trout research by teams under
dr. party's leadership include a BAC
physical map of the genome an integrated
physical and genomic neck a database of
145 k our ad snips a draft assembly of
the rainbow trout genome sequence our ad
sniffs genetic maps for QTL laughing a
57 k snip array the major focal of dr.
parties current research is aimed at
developing and evaluating strategies for
genome enabled selection and traits it
cannot be measured directly on potential
breeders and rainbow trout aquaculture
dr. punky collaborates with other
geneticists research physiologists and
meteorologists microbiologist to math
quantitative trait loci that affect
disease resistance and aquaculture
production efficiency with the
overarching goal of identifying genes
and genetic elements that can be
utilized for improving aquaculture
production efficiency and sustainability
I will now turn it over to dr. Paul T
for his presentation hey Thank You Bobby
for this presentation introduction sorry
and I will get going I have about 20
minutes so it slides it up at the
beginning that are taken from a paper
that we've already published I may go
through them a little bit too fast to
some but please feel free to contact me
can find my email and contact
information online if you need to just
search my name and your
ress contact me and I'll be glad to
share slides and more information of a
lot question that individual scientists
or people in the audience may have so
I'm talking about the 57 k rainbow trout
snip chip that we have developed in
collaboration with the Aqua gene in
siding from Norway and why did we go
with neat cheap at the time we are doing
a rods but they I'm comparing here with
other genotyping by sequencing in
general so typically there are more
snips that you can put on a chip and
analyze simultaneously it's such same or
through food faster and easier and most
a or very very important a standardized
so you can repeat across populations
across studies between different labs
and basically talking about the same
snips will define snips and they're also
the results are very similar in quality
at least we have seen between
experiments and different genotyping
service provider providers it is at the
time when we started was definitely more
expensive then a rod under our hands we
have to do it both say externally so we
do not have a sequencer alumina
sequencer here for a genotyping by
sequencing we also do not have the
equipment that is needed to actually
scan in and do the genotyping with the
axiom so we send everything certainly
but the cost keeps coming down and
recently will say no version that of the
cheap the dampening i mentioned shortly
it's really comparable at least under
our hands and then it is very useful for
applications like population
traceability at least initial to
identify see
the differentiate an example that will
give for my own research for a
genome-wide Association studies and
genomic selection and generating a a
dense genetic linkage map that can be
used that we have been using been using
here with again with our Norwegian
collaborators to improve the rainbow
trout genome so this is really I'll go
through this really briefly because this
is just talking about how and for I've
seen some familiar names among the
attendees so a so like a lot of you
probably know rainbow trout has a recent
tetraploid ization event or whole genome
duplication so there are still
significant portions of the rainbow
trout chromosomes that still are in a
duplicated stage so there can be four
alleles for each marker and then what
were our approach was at least initially
which they was using rods and double
haploid lines homozygous lines nearly
clonal night that we used to try to
filter out they a the touch of tetras
ohmic a PSVs in msv their code i'm not
getting to those definitions right now
but at the end we we had about database
of about 100 almost 150,000 snips that
we we had from rods of double haploids
and all this is published you can see
the bottom there in 2014 the development
of the rods database then this is a from
the actual a when we are actually using
the VRA for validation so you can see
the bottom here is where we published
this information in again in molecular
ecology resources
but we did validation of the actual snip
genotyping array with the almost 1,000
samples that we used for the validation
and you can see here in the middle what
I want to emphasize is that we have a
collaborators from aquagen and side gene
so they have a added a very significant
amount of the snips in the India Rey
that are from Ricci Qin Singh of 12 of
the aquagen fish and then the third
resource for the snips on the airway was
from previously published snips there's
obviously overlap between the snips that
we use we looked for overlap between
those resources in those snakes that we
prefer to choose overall and from the
50-50 7500 snips on the array or spots
on the array almost 50,000 which is
about eighty-six percent were validated
as highly polymorphic snips based on the
criteria that I used with a affymetrix a
software for best practices analysis the
fish in the panel so there were a total
of 960 samples 19 of them are those
double haploid lines that you already
had a previous genotypes for them and
there are also a unrelated populations
almost 300 fish from 18 unrelated
populations aquaculture us aquaculture
populations and some wild populations
and we also had pedigree information
from family that we used for for
additional research but it helped us say
validate within those ten pedigrees that
those are really behaving a Mendelian
inheritance fashion inner hey what are
the truth Nixon or not and then we
looked at polymorphism so in the
aperture populations in the u.s. there
was a very high number of polymer
thick markers almost 41,000 fair
population which is also consistent with
previous genetic research in rainbow
trout that showing that the majority of
the variations within populations in at
least farm populations our culture
populations not between it also worked
very well for a the the group at the
aquagen that co-developed the snip with
us the snip chip with us and I don't
have numbers from their population but
they confirm that the rosary polymorphic
and worked very well for them and in
with wild populations there was smaller
sample size papa bear population but
overall seems like there is a trend that
we saw a lower level of a number of
polymorphic markers where population but
the lowest number was 10,000 which is
still very good for most application and
given the small number i think that
20,000 please would be more likely
number when sample size is larger we
looked at the minor allele frequency and
this is here showing going from very low
level of about egg right here about
point 05 but it keeps going up and the
expanding to almost point five it's a
it's a typical spread we did not
pre-select snips for minor allele
frequency at least not from all
resources so it's a we're pretty happy
and it's again the high level of
polymorphism is an indication that the
minor allele frequency is not a problem
for most of the sniffs with most of the
applications that we have been using
also distribution on the genome so is
showing a in general what we expect to
see the
small number chromosomes are higher
there are the larger chromosomes and it
goes down toward a a the large number
chromosome or smaller in size and with
the two exceptions here to chromosome
that we know from our genome work that
there are some some issues going on with
those chromosomes and that give us we
have good idea why there's higher number
of snips then what expected based on a
chromosome size in the hierarchy on
those this one here the deep one in
chromosome 13 still not sure why we got
a deep their number of snips but overall
and the picture is a good distribution
of snakes from all chromosomes across
the genome so that's a genotyping array
the axiom child genotyping array 57 k is
available online it can be purchased
from a few metrics and it is a there to
version it's kind of hard to see it's a
little bit blurry but there is a in 96
format version and the 384 the 96 means
that they it is doing ninety six samples
at a time in then 384 it's ready for the
time and there's the minimum numbers for
ordering that it can be found out from a
few metrics so you know can also ask me
how I'm ordering it through email and
what numbers aren't dealing with a but
that's basically it's a product that is
commercially available online and then
we use that to develop a dense genetic
map in collaboration it's really are a
Norwegian collaborators and FEMA first
and then they see
bowling at the siding that kept that
work with a large number of families we
developed a genetic linkage map that
allowed us at as guidance to build
chromosome sequences from sequence
scaffolds that we've also done with
other collaborators so what we're seeing
here is on the x-axis is this is a
typical chromosome chromosome 4 is
really behaving very nicely not all
chromosomes obviating that nicely when
we're plotting the genetic linkage
distances for each snip against the
physical distances but that's the
picture perfect and so what we're seeing
here is it's hard to see but they're
small dots each dot is representing a
snip and then we're plotting a flat line
here the bottom one the grey one is the
male the linkage map and there for
people are not familiar with working
with linkage maps in salmaah needs so
there is an area or very lower
combination in most of the chromosome in
the middle that's a typical picture of
what you see in males and then in
females there is a much more proportion
of the genetic distance is much more
proportional to the physical distance
because the combination is much more
even all across the chromosome and then
the result areas of toward the end of
the chromosome of much higher
combination in the males but this is a
really happy to to be able to see that
type of pattern that we expect to see
and it's also a very good way to spot
chromosomal aberrations and other issues
in rainbow trout genome and find out
what area of the chromosome exactly
those are care and we hope to have the
new reference genome
we are in the process of uploading it to
ncbi we hope to have it within six
months expected release to ncbi so
that's that's hopefully coming we've
been waiting for a long time and we're
still more tweaking but it's it's in the
making then the linkage map that we that
we developed we provided samples in
genotype but the barn for Malik analysis
most of it was done in Norway so it was
used in two publications so far for
comparative genomics in the publication
of linear all of the Atlantic salmon in
nature this year was published this year
and publication that our group of just
the food recently and right here it is
in frontiers in genetics we have the
proofs of final version it is available
online already but final version will be
available very soon and they an older
version of the dense linkage map that
include all the snips is on this of
supplemental information in this
publication so and this is I do believe
that people can actually go online and
if you want to download the linkage map
in Excel files it should already be
there supplemental information and for
that portion of the presentation I just
want to acknowledge dr. Gao from my
group they are highlighted in weathers
obviously a lot of collaborators very
important collaborators in the genome
work in the interest of time I mentioned
the biofilm edition from USDA dr. Gao
dr. Martin thomas warren from aquagen
who was a I worked very closely with us
on the native development has done the
snip discovery and data base for the
Aquajet fish and
sick morning and Matthew Kent from sides
into the genotyping and signaling
waterless on the genome in the linkage
map and Matthew Bronski did the initial
the first version of the linkage map
that we have been using and also needs
to acknowledge funding sources for the
development of the array a USDA they
in-house eres funding in the extramural
they in Norway the research council
provided funding for the research there
and aquagen provided their own funding
for genotyping and sequencing of the
fish now I have a few more minutes all a
talk on speaker applications that we
have been using for a genome-wide
Association and for genomic selection of
bacterial cold water disease resistance
and that's here in the National Center
for codes and cold aquaculture of USDA
in midtown west virginia so first i'm
showing the results and this is from a
about the sample size was about 1500 a
fish with phenotypes for disease
resistance and there is a there
different statistical approaches the one
that i'm showing here is called the
single step awaited single step g blob
and that of course i don't have time to
go into all the details and it is in
preparation the results of this the
source population is one of the eight
trout lodge breeding populations that
the using trout lodge is a we have a lot
of prayer is a good research partner
excellent population material we have
done the phenotyping of the fish with a
lab challenge here and what we can see
is we can map the sneaks back to the
chromosomes and we can look what I'm
showing here is I Manhattan plot we're
on
whew the arrows here so this is showing
as a percentage on the on the y-axis is
a percentage of genetic variation that
is affected and actually the snips that
they are showing it's what each one of
those points here is a window of 20
snips that are adjacent to each other we
use the linkage map the first version of
the linkage map as a reference here and
so too it's there are different ways of
doing the analysis but we found whatever
you are a statistical genomics here has
identified that in windows of 20 snips
it was optimized a way to reduce
background noise to signal so we found
three a major chromosomes was strong
effect of those a long sigh of adjacent
snip so it's a 25 and it's 25 8 and
three that has a strong signal and there
are weaker signals a smaller qpl on
other chromosomes but i'm going to move
and focus on just chromosome 8 and
basically showing now how using the gos
and the knowledge we have for the
linkage map and the physical map we can
now all those tools allow us to focus on
the area of the genome where those snip
windows are and much faster than we you
could do in the past really
okay and much faster than we could use
during the past focus on is a
chromosomal region the what you see in
red there are the snips here it shifts
each dot represents an actual snip
another snip window so those that are
highlighted in red are the actual is
snips from the QTL regions with a signal
that give a signal to coldwater disease
resistance and they the correlation is
not as nice as the previous a chromosome
that I've shown because we use the older
version of the linkage maps not
everything falls in order but hey I need
to move forward so this is for
illustration only now that we have a
genome this is actually using the a
genome browser that has a previous
genome from the energy noscope group
that was published previously in nature
communication 2014 the new genome is
still we do not have it internally on
genome browser and a it will take time
but basically genome browser they're
different software that allow you to
upload data into a genome browsers and
what I'm trying to show here is how we
can put the snips from the snip chip
down here in this area are the slips
from the large database that we have and
this is showing this is one of the
pieces of the chromosome that actually
had a a chromosome sequence in in an
order that they were able to orient it
order the scaffolds on the genome so
this is a big picture of how the snips
are can be aligned with the genome and
then just blowing it up a little bit so
we can already see how in here i'm just
showing snips from this
perret each one of those here represent
a snip of those fat supplemental
sniffles snippet and this is just to
illustrate that they can be aligned with
predicted exomes or can be if or can't
fall in areas that are between genes but
that way if you know which snips are
associated with your trade of interest
you can further focus on what genes are
in that area what other genomic
sequences and elements on that area of
the chromosome in the genome and the
last application I really I guess need
to speed through that is genome
selection and so typically sip selection
is used in traits like a disease where
the fish can be from the same family
same some of the siblings can be
phenotype for example a they can be
challenging a disease challenge and then
there's if those fish are genotyped this
is called the training population for a
genome selection because you can have
genotypes and phenotypes from the same
fish and then you can genotype their
siblings and predict the genetic merit
of the siblings for the trade the whites
been done traditionally is just based on
pedigree and phenotypes in which case
there is only genetic merit prediction
for the entire family so all they in the
selection candidates the testing
population all the buzzards and sisters
have the same genetic merit prediction
versus with genome selection we can
assign specific values based on the
genotypes through the today a testing
population to the potential breeders and
then this is just showing that it worked
very well for Coldwater disease
resistance in the same population and
this this is actually a second
vision now it it is going to be
published soon this work and so
basically what it is showing here is
that for each a paternal let's look here
this is a paternal half sleep so the
same male was mated with two sisters one
sister in the redhead hello a genetic
match prediction for Coldwater disease
resistance in blue had the high a
predicted married and we can see that at
the end there was about the average was
about twenty percent higher and this is
unfortunate testing so this is actually
after this challenge of the offspring of
those courses were each time a one male
was made of those two sisters one with a
predicted law of genetic merit and one
with high and we were able to confirm it
just based on differences so this is
just differences between a female
parents and we can find a really strong
response and that's all in a lab desk
for the challenge so it has correlation
with field performance but it's not we
don't expect the field performance to
the to be as big as what we see in the
lab but it is confirming the accuracy of
the predictions and this is another way
of looking at it a little bit larger
sample that's the whole population that
that we looked at of 138 families again
this is based on their progeny
performance so we correlated here they
predicted genetic merit we recorded the
predicted genetic marriage here's the
genome and predictions for a the two
parents we averaged wrong predictions
for the two parents and plotted them
against the
actually survival of the actual
performance of the offspring and we're
seeing very good correlation correlation
is a point seven one which which is very
good accuracy this is how we measure the
accuracy of the prediction where a the
average the genome prediction of the
parents is a very good predictor of
whether the offspring from that family
with what will be the survival of the
progeny from the disease challenge on
the other hand if we look at the
traditional pedigree based and again
this is a day it's known as a blob model
which is on using pedigree and
phenotypes to predict and the same
correlations of the mid parents value
correlated against the actual a
performance mid progeny performance and
here the correlation was 0 point 35 so
using the traditional approach which way
we have been using with our experimental
USDA population successful in the past
we have achieved progress but it is
showing that we're almost doubling the
accuracy of the prediction so that
clearly save it that we can not only we
can distinguish between a offspring or
between sisters within the family or
brother whether a one of them will be a
better breather for a cold water
resistant than the other we can also see
that overall the population there's much
better accuracy a also in ranking
between families and overall we're
doubling the accuracy of the genome
breeding prediction and I think I hope I
did not go too fast here but again these
are all resulted are in the process of
review or being submitted to
publications coming soon so just the
last night before acknowledgments to
summarize how they
normal selection technology has already
been used by the industry so our oxygen
there were our collaborators our
co-developer of the other snip and they
have successfully identify markers that
are associated with IP and V resistance
in rainbow trout they had done it before
and Sam another dungeon child and
actually selling eggs to their customers
the farmers that are a that have
increased ipn resistance based on the
genome information and trout lodge is
going to offer in this may coming May
for that population they're going to
offer added value product it will be
fished them that have better called
water resistance and those are done
based on the genome merit predictions
from the study that we have done with
them and again obviously it's a a lot of
collaborators in a group that I have to
acknowledge right so I'm going to have
to mention the primaries here a dr.
Vallejo and leaves form from the USDA
that a are the quiet Roger is a
statistical genomics guy in Tim leave
the quantity of geneticist but we have a
large group the fish disease health
Jason avenues was a weed scientist from
the fish shells on the challenges and
phenotype in there doing a lot of work
on that and then our industry
collaborators the leadership there from
there are rd is Jim Parsons and Kyle
Martin that have been excellent
collaborators really an asset for us as
government scientists to demonstrate to
the industry
the potential of the technology costs of
course and there are other issues but
definitely we've demonstrated the
potential in technology and there we
have an excellent support groups called
support is scientists and technicians
here that deal with the molecular lab
work with the fish fish handling fish
breeding and we also got a lot of advice
and help from groups and University of
Georgia and I was stated and that are
still developing have developed a
still-developing the algorithm in
programs for statistical genomics for
and genome merit prediction and also for
the ng was that but that I've seen
before and I think that with that I can
stop in and be ready to take questions
well thank you very much for your
presentation dr. and I would like to
remind our audience at us any questions
you can submit questions by typing them
in the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we're going to try to answer as many
questions as time allows dr. Paul T my
first question is is why do you choose
the axiom array over the snip genotyping
technologies okay so at the time and
when when we looked at our options the
main a main reason was cost so it's not
a secret that they the the competing
still today but it definitely the time
which is 2013 is when we're ready to
start working with Nietzsche please the
alumina bidar a technology the alumina
has an advantage of more flexibility in
number of samples you don't have to
start with 96 samples a time for example
but the cost for this number of snips
was not not even comparable so it was
definitely much more
affordable specially for the large type
of projects that we are interested in
that are the core developers of the
array from no way we're interested in
doing at the time okay dr. Paul tu su tu
cost and what are the current costs and
what does the cost coming down me okay
so the cost that that I'm seeing now for
the 300 when i'm using the 384 a well
version and with that we have to start
with at least 1920 samples but my costs
currently the last geo typing contracted
i have is a eight sixty dollars a sample
when we started with the 96-well format
and three years ago then my cost was
about over one hundred and twenty
dollars a sample so that that's the way
i see it on a consumer I can I have good
estimate this this includes a the actual
cost of the array that the genotyping
provider is a pain to alpha metrics to
purchase it from our metrics and their
costs there added cost of the labor and
overhead whatever they need to take and
probably some profit that they need to
take from doing the genotyping so all I
do is I meringue my DNA samples in 96 or
384-well plate a certain amount use it's
about 500 nanograms per sample and I'm
sending it out and I'm receiving back
there large files of overall data and
then I go from there I'm putting it on
the pipeline of computer that is that
can be downloaded for free there's
there's very useful manuals and software
provided free of charge
from a few metrics that can be
downloaded and used to analyze the data
and I guess that's I can stop here okay
thank you we do have time for one last
question and what is the sensitivity of
the chick to DNA quality and quantity
what was that again can your people not
a problem yeah what is what is this if
what is the sensitivity of the chip to
DNA quality and quantity we haven't
messed too much with it becoming we have
a good quality being a because we're
we're doing lab experiments you know
it's not we're not too limited but a the
only information that I have is when we
try to use other cell monies that are
not rainbow trout and to see if we can
genotype other even cutthroat trout
which is relatively it genetically close
to rainbow trout una evolutionary scale
so wear it a lot of the chips other
snips on the cheaper already not
validated maybe half of them and it just
didn't go we had to exclude those
samples because it didn't pass through
the quality control threshold for
genotyping but I mean we we always try
to send at least 500 nano grams of a
good quality genomic DNA that we can
obtain we do have every once in a while
samples that fail but typically it's and
we get over ninety seven percent of the
samples to come back with good genotypes
thank you
dr. Ponti do you have any final comments
before we let you go today and now thank
you very much it was really a increase
the productivity of our research
immensely to work with this array and
against the people of the audience I
know that my email is not on the
presentation but it's it's very easy to
find me online or through publications
if there are follow-up questions that
people want to fold either through today
webcast or directly to my email now I'll
be glad to I know that I were I had to
go through some of the things very fast
thank you very much well thank you dr.
paltan also like to thank dr. Beecham
for his presentation as well I also like
to thank our sponsor thermo fisher
scientific today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
April 2017 you'll receive an email alert
from lavaridge when this webcast will be
available for replay we invite you to
for that announcement to your colleagues
who've made missed today's live event
until next time goodbye